different take on the u.s economy maybe
it's it isn't really shrinking
a wall street journal uh economic output
can be measured two different ways
growth domestic product or growth
domestic income for every dollar an
individual spends to buy some good or
service a restaurant meal a car a
doctor's visit another individual earns
a dollar of income to make and deliver
that good or service gdp captures the
spending side of these transactions gdi
is the income side some economists look
for clearer picture by averaging gdp and
gdi the average measure of output barely
moved at all
rising at a 0.2 annual rate adjusted for
inflation over the uh first six months
of the year this is more consistent with
a stalling economy than one in recession
what are your thoughts on that tom well
okay
my car was stalling
and it comes to a stop
right versus recession it's it's sort of
like them saying
right sort of like they're saying
it's not horrible it's only terrible
yeah you know
you're being too hard on us it's not
horrible it's merely terrible it's not a
category five hurricane it's only a
category three meanwhile almost got hit
by a cow flying by yeah right
so i i think this is this is spin this
is pure
spin so some economists look for a
clearer picture by averaging so this is
nothing more in the white house saying
hey we don't like two quarters the
two-quarter rule is outdated that's a
measurement we don't like we don't want
to call it a recession because we don't
want to measure and that's probably an
outdated measure remember that two weeks
ago
and so
they're trying to find
every spin they can because bill clinton
was right it's the economy stupid
james carville
well i think it was james carfield that
said that tom come
know your people now tom he wrote the
script but bill delivered it beautifully
that's right it was correct and as we go
into the midterms it's the economy
stupid and what's going on here is make
sure media is complicit and trying to
find every way to
sort of spin and to say that a category
five hurricane is not as bad as a
category three yeah but what is tom what
do you think about the fact that the
journal wrote this like that that kind
of surprised me it seemed a little out
of step for the journal i could see this
from cnbc
or washington post or what have you but
it does seem a little out of step that
the journal would publish this actually
a great point by tyler why do you say
out of step though
because i think i find the truth real
quick do you find them to be credible or
not credible yeah okay and that's my
point is that they they seem to cut
through the nonsense and the spin and i
relay the facts i don't i don't think
they're particularly one-sided i think
if anything maybe they're center-right i
think their own body they are definitely
center-right i think they're owned by uh
murdoch's group if i'm not mistaken um
his media group but typically they cut
through the nonsense and the spin and it
seems this seems a little out of step
and
just off
you're ultimately saying that you don't
agree with tom and you'd like to have a
debate with him now on the facts right
now i think what he's saying is why is
wall street journal saying the market is
not as bad where they're supposed to be
their position ought to be more of
we are in recession rather no we're not
really in a recession so i think that's
what tyler's saying it's a great
question um
cramer i think was yesterday or the day
before they said
if the the this trend is showing that
the market's going to come back up by
the end of the year it's going to be a
big uptick on the market by the end i
don't know if you saw that or not what
kramer said yesterday
about the market the reality right now
is
no one really knows what's gonna happen
okay no one really knows what's gonna
happen there's way too many
charts that you're looking at that are
going one side or the other side
but you you have to look at a couple
things uh one of the one is the next
story that's coming up right now which
i'm reading to you 3.8 million renters
will likely be evicted in the next two
months that's a lot of people tyler
three point two
million right as pandemic eviction
moratoriums expire and rent payment
relief programs and across the u.s a
rental crisis is beginning to crest
about 8.5 million people are behind on
rent
as of end of august that's a lot of
people to be behind on rent according to
census bureau data of those renters
around 3.8 million say they are somewhat
or very likely to be evicted over the
next two months meanwhile rent continues
to tick up and top that 2 000 a month in
june for the first time on record on
record before the pandemic rents have
increased by almost 25 and 15
in just the past year according to
zillow evictions are spiking in major
cities across the country as well in
tampa florida evictions were
52 percent above average in august
according to the eviction lab at
princeton university in houston they
were 90
above average and in minneapolis st paul
they were 94 above average so
there's different worlds people live in
the world wall street journal maybe more
lives in their audience are earners
their audience are people that are
making money and this is owner i would
love to see the average reader of a wall
street journal like many people may read
l.a times
new york times new york post usa today
you know all that stuff but the person
that reads one like i've given wall
street journal to a couple of our guys
and i said look my suggestion is for you
to read wall street journal and they'll
read and they're like
the hell are they talking about what i
don't understand this don't like but but
that's why you already read the sports
section you ought to read it to see
what's going on with this so
they are talking to their audience
that's in this world and those guys are
probably not going to be affected as
much yeah okay what did an average
income is bad for somebody that's a wall
street journal reader i would say the
average income earner reading wall
street journal is 200 i was going to say
150 to 200 grand yeah you think it's
that high i think it's 150 to 200.
that is the one percent or the top i
mean
five percent i think it's ten percent by
the way you know
to make the six figures is twenty
percent okay yeah so top ten percent is
around one fifty two hundred i think
it's top ten percent yeah that's about
the number yeah so i think that's their
readership and they're speaking to their
audience but yeah this
3.8 million evictions yeah this
94 percent in saying you know saint paul
or 90 in houston or you know the numbers
like this
american people are feeling it yeah just
go to the streets and ask them how do
you feel about what's going on with your
finances so they'll tell you this is
main street to your point wall street
journal puts together something says if
you take these two statistics and you
put them together like this and look at
this perhaps it looks like this okay
great
meanwhile on main street
guess what the party's over and this
goes back two years ago the deeper story
behind this
pat this goes back two years ago when
remember when the federal government
prevented evictions cdc moratorium and
states prevented evictions everybody's
saying wait does the cdc even have the
authority to prevent me from evicting
somebody here in atlanta and apparently
they did
so this goes back this goes back two
years i'll give you a crazy story here
i'll give you a crazy story here
a person
who
made
little less than a million dollars last
year
made good money last year
we get an email and the email is
she would like to be the director of hr
for valuetainment
and i'm like wait what
yes
how why
i know where you live you live in a
beautiful place
in one of these
high rises i know what car you picked me
up when we were going and doing the lone
paperwork
you told me how you did the last three
four or five years
director of hr is not a you know a
salary that's going to pay you anything
you know it's one-tenth of what you made
last year is what you're going to get
paid for salary like that
why are you applying
the industry is so dry right now it's
not even funny wow okay
lols right now in america are not
getting hit five percent 10 or 20
percent
they're destroyed tyler when i say
destroyed i'm talking 90 percent
dry you know what 90 is let me give you
a paint a picture for you here what this
means
imagine you run a mcdonald's every day
to your mcdonald's 500 people come in
i'm just giving you a number
what would happen to that mcdonald's if
they went from 500 customers coming in
to take 90
only 50 people coming in so what what
happens to that quiznos what happens to
that jeffy lube what happens to that
movie theater what happens to that
restaurant what
90
of lo's income is gone
where is that felt
a card that sold for 1.75 million
dollars kobe bryant card
last year black label rookie card you
know what you just sold for on auction
last week 8.50
in one year it went down 50
who was buying collectible cards crypto
guys mortgage guys real estate guys you
have to know that
that is felt okay period there is no
wall street journal can write an article
like that and say the fact that it's not
really a recession it's more like a
stagnation or more like a flat whatever
no problem we have haven't experienced
foreclosure yet it ain't gonna happen
for another six months well it's that
was my next question what do you think
happens to foreclosures after these 3.8
million renters get evicted so the 3.8
million renters get evicted they can't
pay the landlord who owns the house the
landlord who owns the house has no money
coming in how is he going to afford that
second home that he's renting out do you
see do you see foreclosure spike do do
the house that we we look we just looked
at a place do you remember the place we
looked yes so we went into balcony where
i looked the view was incredible the
view was incredible
we did have a moment
okay so so anyways we're at this place
back to the balcony what would you say
about this what would you say about this
building what would you say about this
building the most elite building in all
of miami okay and the place we looked at
can you tell give them a
visual tour of what this place looked
like
oh that's um number one it's
i mean can i say how much the apartment
this is this is a house or a building
this is this is the penthouse of the
penthouse of a 54th floor
your elevator move comes up to the floor
i'm thinking about buying this place the
entire place is 10 000 square feet
swimming pool on the 56th floor i mean
it's just it's that kind of a place
we're going to put parties entertain all
so i want to buy this place and i want
to and i said i want to see this place
yeah i text him i got the realtor the
next day we go look at this place yeah
boom boom so we'll go look at this place
and the realtor says uh uh well they had
on the market for 33 million dollars
just last year yeah but it's on a deal
right now for twenty six point nine
million i was gonna say it was gonna
listen at 26. it's a building where all
the who's who's in miami live in this
building like you say their names they
live in this building and i'm saying
names yeah won't say they live in this
building okay
so i look at the realtor what do i tell
the realtor at the end i'm gonna make an
offer and it might offend you
she says she says don't offend me i said
i'm gonna make an offensive offer
no no but but i said i'm gonna make i'm
gonna make an offer and it may offend
you but here's the thing this thing's
not gonna sell right for the number that
they want but i have cash i'll cut you
check but i'm gonna make an offer that's
gonna offend you you know you're gonna
sell this for 30 million dollars in the
next five years exactly five years i get
to benefit for being prepared taking the
reason
and you take a hit because you sat on
there trying to sell it for a high price
so those are the
where you see the top earner all of a
sudden having to go from trying to sell
it for 32 last year he's probably going
to end up selling you for less than half
of last year okay so these things that
you read about it's great for papers
it's great to get the stock broker or
the hedge fund manager to talk to his
clients and say did you see what the
wall street journal said today they said
it's not as bad as you okay let's put
another five million dollars into the
market today but in reality
the street the real people that are
doing what they're doing it's being held
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]